vão morrer gente nossa tema hoje que é
um tema difícil
depressão é o que eu vou falar pra vocês
eu já tive momentos muito difíceis com
um psiquiatra e eu já não consegui
salvar todas as vidas que passaram no
meu consultório
isso doeu demais dentro de mim porque eu
sou médica eu quero ajudar as pessoas e
com eu não consegui salvar todas as
vidas das quais não atende
isso foi doloroso e foi difícil e ou
então senti que a minha natureza não era
a mesma mas é preciso começar a contar
pra vocês a minha primeira natureza
quando era muito pequenininha me deram
de presente uma vassourinha de bruxa ea
um gostei não fui lavar o quintal com a
vassoura para ver se tirava sujeira
depois um pouco mais tarde
meus pais me deram tá e lindo pra que eu
fosse o teatro municipal de são paulo
assistir os balés
eu fiquei muito enquadrada naquele taher
apertado mas de repente durante balé
quando vi as fadas que eu me encontrei e
consegui me ver ali eu era uma na minha
imaginação a minha primeira natureza se
descobria eu nasci pra ajudar as pessoas
realizarem seus desejos
bom mas é um tema que eu vim falar pra
vocês e depressão que que se tem a ver
com a história das fadas
o show começa a contar pra vocês aos 12
anos de idade
eu fiz o meu primeiro diagnóstico não
foi fácil para mim
infelizmente foi na minha própria mãe
leucemia aguda
ela morreu logo em seguida
e eu tive que através dela para belo
horizonte estava
de camburiú trabalho teve que pegar um
avião para poder providenciar o enterro
e os meus dois irmãozinhos um de 10 e 11
ante 7 estavam comigo e não havia
ninguém que soubesse o caminho e subia e
assim eu trouxe o carro da funerária de
balneário de camburiú a belo horizonte
ao parque da colina e no dia seguinte de
manhã eu chegava ao cemitério e quando
eu vi a cara do meu pai
ao invés de chorar sorrir eu fiquei
alegre
eu fiquei feliz que fique feliz na hora
mais triste da minha vida como isso
poderia acontecer
minha primeira grande lição eu aprendi
que dor e sofrimento todo mundo vai ter
não existe como escapa mas nós podemos
ter um propósito para viver e sair da
dor e foi aí que eu decidir ser médica
mas eu não queria ser só uma médica eu
queria ser uma fada médica bons anos
passar eu fui procurá-la no crm fada
médica gente não tinha não o jeito vai
ser psiquiatra mesmo assim eu comecei a
minha jornada mas aí começaram as minhas
grandes dificuldades
eu fui me encontrar com uma coisa
chamada de pressão todos os dias o dia
inteiro no meu consultório pior
a organização mundial de saúde já avisou
em 2030 ela será a primeira doença no
mundo a tirar a capacidade de trabalho
das pessoas
esse terrível e sabem por quê porque a
doença depressão é a única doença
psiquiátrica
de acordo com o pne que vocês já viram
aí ela pode ser adquirida
acontece que muitas pessoas vão se
deprime e sabe por que elas não se
deprimir multitarefas do e muito táctico
gente estudando quem não dorme tarde as
pessoas que têm mais obrigações do que
deveriam fazer
as pessoas que se obrigam o stress da
vida cotidiano e no nosso consultório
psiquiátrico e não só nosso mas de todos
os médicos o que mais aparecem são as
doenças causadas pela depressão
as doenças autoimunes o câncer
as pessoas tendo ataques do coração e
sim por diante
lá atrás muitos anos atrás a doença
depressiva começavam por volta dos 30
anos depois lá pelos anos 70 60 a doença
depressiva começou nos jovens adultos
hoje no consultório da gente nós vemos
as crianças deprimidas e temos que dar
remédio para essas crianças
isso é terrível quem vocês vão dizer
doença depressiva depressão uma doença
genética
sim ela é uma doença genética mas você
já ouviu falar de efigênia ea e shane a
mudança do gem por conta do stress e as
pessoas podem adquirir a depressão
bom agora só vou tentar mas então quem
quer depressão você vem falar de
depressão
a filha da médica veio falar de pressão
depressão é uma doença que vem do nada
marcado pelo seu genro e você fica
triste você chora
você pára de ter vontade de fazer as
coisas você perde a esperança você tem
um sentimento de inutilidade
você não quer mais fazer nada e com isso
você perde a sua capacidade de trabalho
você perde os seus amigos você perde a
sua família você perde seu emprego você
vai encostando um sofá e fica no buraco
negro até que uma doença te pegue você
morra é isso que acontece com uma pessoa
deprimida quando não é parte de um
quadro muito pior que a doença da
bipolaridade ou não escutas já devem ter
ouvido falar dessa doença ocorre é grave
olha nesses anos todos da minha vida
profissional são 35 anos trabalhando
como psiquiatra com depressão
eu nunca vi tanta gente deprimida e pior
eu tenho tentado e como eu já disse a
vocês
eu não consegui salvar todas as vidas e
eu não consegui salvar todas as vidas
que alguns citaram inclusive jovens e
jovens médicos
eu não consegui salvar vidas porque não
tomaram as medidas ações como eu pedir
eu não consegui salvar vidas porque os
deprimidos não quiseram ficar tomando
remédio porque é feio tomar remédio
psiquiátrico eu não consegui salvar
vidas
mesmo dando os melhores remédios do
mundo eu não consegui salvar vidas com a
minha generosidade ou só com a minha
gentileza
foi aí que eu parei um momento e comecei
a me questionar está errado que me
lembrei de um episódio que aconteceu na
minha própria vida
aos 13 anos eu pedi à minha mãe aos 15
anos 1975 houve uma grande aliada no
estado de são paulo
meu pai era cafeicultor ele perdeu todo
o café zão nesse dia ele teve uma úlcera
supurada estava morrendo esvaindo em
sangue
o capataz da fazenda tinha saído
proteger as vacas com o carro
a fazenda ele morrendo eu só tinha ele e
um caminhão
o primeiro hospital mais próximo ficava
a 50 quilômetros vale não tive dúvida eu
fui levar meu pai se um dia entre vivos
ea morte eu consegui salvar todo mundo
levando a minha mãe é o desejo dela era
ser enterrado em belo horizonte porque
não poderia dirigir um caminhão
peguei o caminhão se eo pé e foi embora
e seja o que deus quiser quero meu pai e
eu cheguei
cheguei lá com o meu pai e salvei a vida
dele
minha segunda lição de vida a gente pode
ter força pra passar os momentos
difíceis e eu descobrir e resgatavam
aquela lembrança a menina que um dia que
ser ao fado e resgatar wafa da médica e
foi então que eu pensei como
é que fosse salvar como uma médica fada
como eu vou salvar as pessoas eu fui
atrás e eu encontrei só que eu encontrei
gente um caminho flores florescer
eu encontrei um novo modelo de fazer
psiquiatria
eu sei que eu estou inovando eu
encontrei a psicologia positiva eu
encontrei a neurociência eu encontrei a
meditação em letra dentro do meu
consultório e aí é que foi feita grande
diferença na minha vida das pessoas que
trabalham comigo dos meus clientes
eu consegui mostrar pra eles através da
psicologia positiva que eles tinham algo
bom quando eu ensinava coisas óbvias da
psicologia positiva agradecer dá graças
ao que é de graça uma graça divina
quando você agradece gratidão primeiro
prefeito da psicologia positiva você faz
a pessoa ver o que funciona eo deprimida
jogar lá no que não funciona na
desesperança
então eu sabia que aquilo iria dar certo
e era o que eu estava fazendo naquele
momento
além disso na psicologia positiva
nós conseguimos fazer a pessoa focar no
que funciona
tem tantas coisas que funciona e que
podem dar certo quando fez uma janela
assim outra quando fez uma ponta de cima
janela e ali eu punha à luz e foco e na
psicologia positiva
você aprende a mostrar as habilidades
que as pessoas têm o que ela pode fazer
de bom e aí entra a neurociência e eu
sou da ciência eu acredito na ciência
sou médica de natureza e na minha outra
natureza fada
queria mostrar que existe um caminho o
caminho do epigenoma o caminho da
mudança genética a neuroplasticidade sem
ensinar as pessoas a mudar o caminho de
como elas pensavam nos poderiam ser
totalmente diferente
isso sabe ensinar eu sabia o olhar o que
era abel eu sabia ver o que funcionava e
essa neuroplasticidade foi o que eu fiz
eu quero mostrar pra vocês uma foto de
belo horizonte muito conhecida
um prédio de oscar niemeyer praça da
liberdade p cor de rosa representa belo
horizonte
esse modelo é um modelo da psiquiatria
tradicional a minha psiquiatria é que
preza saúde mental
nesse modelo nós vamos os galhos vazios
tudo vazio mas no meu modelo
a gente vê a vida assim a gente enxerga
for no meio do vazio a gente enxergar
flor que existe em cada pessoa e o nosso
olhar muda tudo faz crescer o que há de
belo dente de alguém e é isso que muda
as pessoas e foi isso que eu passei a
fazer e foi muito legal
bom eu quero terminar com um poema com
ela que eu mesmo escrevi
vocês me desculpem eu não sou poetisa
mas meus é fazer isso
o meu mundo ele é diferente é o enxergo
diferente
eu tenho olhos para ver um mundo
eu vim de um mundo que é de amor e luz
fim de onde o amor cura tudo de onde a
escuridão transparece ea dor te fornece
ela esvanece de onde a luz se faz no
haiti sol
aquele que entra pela fresta da janela
do mundo que eu vim
o gol chega maior tem sorriso tem abraço
tem um olhar de amor
inclusive eu da minha filha lá em
florestas têm flores e água com
cachoeira e omar é linda ilha diferente
com raiados ou xp
eles espalham pela água e refletem muita
luz de onde eu vim gente sabe a cada pra
mim
de manhã este meu coração e faz saltar
da cama logo cedo e sempre querendo
ajudar as pessoas a buscar o que é belo
o que é bom de hoje eu vi o jogo de soma
soma de 20 o que a gente tem para ficar
mais forte
o pão o conhecimento e também o amor eu
vejo um lugar diferente sim eu tenho
amor tem luz encher sementes a luz lá
forma novas estrelas pelo mundo
alunos de lá abre os novos caminhos à
circuitaria neuronal
ela abre as portas das esperanças para
quem não tem mais esperança a esse lugar
é lindo especial por isso eu sou
diferente de hoje eu vim eu aprendia
buscar as belezas encantar as vidas
trazia luz e escuridão assim eu sou
diferente
eu me abasteço do canto dos pássaros das
flores das cores da chuva do sol do
perfume de lavanda a como eles enchem a
minha alma de paz amor e luz
você pode achar que o meu mundo não
existe mas ele existe sem viu ele está
aqui dentro de mim dentro do meu coração
e se você também vive comigo sentiu
presente é fácil encontrar porque você
pode ver o meu mundo é o seu mundo tão
bem
eu apenas chama esse mundo de encantar
para o momento
fique quieto
a spirit devagar e sinta o silêncio
entrará perceba e dentro do seu coração
esse lugar de onde eu vim
ele existe também gente entro de vocês é
a sua essência ele está em cada um de
nós
ele mora no fundo do seu coração e eu
quero dizer pra vocês terminando aqui
agora que eu espero que você vá vá para
o seu caminho
a gente não consegue fazer a diferença
para o mundo inteiro mas a gente pode
fazer o efeito borboleta
eu sei que eu posso mudar uma única
pessoa e se eu mudar uma pessoa eu posso
mudar o mundo
que tal você também ser diferente e
sentir o seu coração
obrigado
[Música]